I mean if if you wanted to argue that
China did it on purpose
that makes substantially more sense than
the globalists are coming for Trump I
know because China's China's
authoritarian they know that we are not
as resilient as they are in the sense
that they will literally lock their own
people in camps there's nothing anyone
can do to stop them and it did and they
get them in there yep and for us we've
got constitutional freedoms which makes
it harder for us to manage this stuff
although life is better at the
individual level we build and develop a
lot faster they've sort of hybridized
this like it's a Communist Party that
uses capitalist mechanisms to the worst
possible degree to rapidly mass-produce
and expand and it's and it's like it's
created that they're they're now a very
powerful country so I really don't think
this case I'll tell you what what makes
way more sense than anything else
they are polluted they're there they eat
gutter oil and they got sick and then
that when when the doctors tried warning
people which could have ended this very
quickly the government didn't want to
look bad so they started arresting the
doctors and destroying evidence which
allowed it to rapidly spread yeah so
look this is what the problem with
authority anism is they seem to think
that one person you know one person is a
better leader than the entirety of the
country working together and distributed
you know form it to an extent they're
correct they can move quickly but then
you end up with one guy whose ego is
bruised and he's like don't tell anybody
not on my watch looks bad and now it
looks real bad yeah but in the same
sense you know I have family in Sweden
who you know Nisha is worried about them
because the the government doesn't work
the same way they don't have that a
figurehead that goes we need to do this
that we're doing this you tell your
people to lock everything down not
necessarily like you know a quarantine
but they're having issues because you
know now there's a corona virus just hit
one of the cities and someone tested
positive but the schools are still open
because no one they haven't decided to
lock everything down yet or close
schools or you know do all the necessary
steps it's lower yeah well it they need
like the whole public to go we should do
this and then they do it exactly and
then that by that point when the public
is saying Oh
we should do this that's kind of a
little too late so we're way better off
than they are so I heard that Finland
shut down like lockdown labor lockdown
like California like we are over here
okay so what is the difference do you
think between Finland and Sweden oh I
don't know no no Finland's pretty
efficient I don't know anything about
Finland yeah well I mean well it's an
assumption yeah yes it's it's also up
there but they're different countries I
know that she's a Scandinavian esteem
aid stereotypes about you based on hate
geez no this is this is what I often
tell the the lefties like the far left
anarchy types know the problem with
anarchy what doesn't work is that you're
you're too far away from from a
hierarchical structure of authority yeah
so these way to explain it is if you
take in a fully authoritarian regime
where one guy dictates mm-hmm
he's gonna point his finger at that
anarchist to calm you know whatever you
know and he's gonna say wipe him out and
then they're gonna sit there and
squabble and vote on how to react and
then it's too late and then they get
wiped out yeah however there's there's
another problem too like I mentioned
with with China you end up with these
leaders who take everything so
personally and want to be in control so
much but they're not capable of adapting
quickly they don't know everything yeah
so they end up doing things like I don't
want to look bad so let's just see this
under the rug and it'll all go away and
then you end up seeing everything gets
really really bad yeah so we have we
have kind of a hybrid in that you know
Trump could say something and he gets
called out for it really really quickly
and then course corrects well you know a
lot of people will say maybe it wasn't
soon enough I don't care man look Trump
came out and he said don't worry about
it's gonna go to zero it's like the flu
and that was a mistake and then you know
we current we can happen later but he
but he flipped yeah he's much much much
faster than then China did because
there's now reports that China may have
known about this since November yeah
like mid January before they actually
start doing anything so when you have we
have one guy in charge and he's
desperately thinking I can stop this
where Ellen finds out then it spreads
faster whereas if he just said you know
if you come out you say here's what
we're facing people could have taken
could have reacted much more quickly
yeah and they ended up with like 80 some
odd thousand people in their country
affected that we know of but then here's
here's the
advantage they have in the long run
mm-hmm see in China it's legal to weld
people's doors shut and barricade them
in their home so they die without
supplies yeah and then when videos come
out showing they unseal this door and
there's just two people dead on the
ground they said no no that's fake news
that's just they fainted and now they're
all better yeah now they're not here to
prove this but I love that we're we're
just like those people well they fainted
and then won the lottery and why where
they're enjoying American cuisine and
they're gone you know you can't
interview them I'm sorry they're they
want to be left alone mm-hmm and so
everyone kind of knows what they're
doing but they get away with it that's
that's so you know I've talked people
about the pros and cons of
authoritarianism and I don't mean pros
in the sense that like you would like
what it is but the system can move very
very fast and and effectively but the
problem is humans have certain wants and
needs and eventually when you have an
authoritarian regime telling everyone
what you can or can't do 24/7 then
people just burnt to the ground
yeah so you know from why do you think
it hasn't happened yet in China prior to
the ground yeah um I think they're
getting started now I think I think
what's scary about where we're headed is
that the power of the surveillance state
might make it impossible so you have an
ever-expanding the population is growing
much too large yeah people are having a
harder time synchronizing on what they
want to do or what could happen it's
much it's much easier for the government
to use artificial intelligence and
algorithms to track certain levels of
dissent and then go and disappear people
so there was you know interesting I mean
in the same sense though the the they
wanted the people of Wuhan to thank him
she sure doing such a good job and they
were like excuse me that's not happening
right and there's all right maybe we
shouldn't do that then
but here's interesting though because
that's basically standing up to them it
is enough for them to care about I don't
know it's an issue of do you have enough
food do you have shelter and do you feel
like there is a light at the end of the
tunnel yeah so was reading about the
Arab Spring countries and what what led
to major revolts and you know like these
countries getting sort of purged and
it's when food becomes too expensive so
long as the people in China can have
shelter food and feel secure then you're
not gonna get anybody overthrown if they
leave their homes to go get food because
they were locked in their homes I mean
they can't write revolt is it her locked
that's what I was saying the problem of
authoritarianism is it comes to a point
yeah where the the leaders screw
something up starts panicking and then
you might end up with major revolt you
know the challenges they can see it now
with social media right and so as as
soon as one person starts saying I'm
sick and tired of this did you see that
there was this video of a guy lot of in
a chair in shackles and they and the
cops were interrogating him and they
said why did you post a bad things about
the police and the man said it was it
was a joke I was drunk I'm sorry and
look you were drunk you thought it was
okay that when you were drunk to say
these things he goes no no it'll never
happen again I'm so sorry please I'm so
sorry and they kept making him say it so
I think the surveillance state now
allows them to suppress you and also
social media allows them to create this
social pressure as well so if you look
like that what happened in Sweden when I
think it was expressed in the newspaper
went to people's homes apparently this
is what is it by her and I want to be
very careful when we get sued but they
had hacked into Disqus a comment system
and then used that information to track
down anonymous commenters on the
internet and then shame them oh yeah you
we were talking about right so here's
what happens right you might think oh
man I'm so sick and tired of the
government who I want a revolt or
something and then all of a sudden you
start getting a bunch of messages saying
what's wrong with you you're so not cool
oh you're a loser and you start feeling
social pressure and then they start
shaming you and then all of a sudden you
get inundated with all these people
saying like wow what an awful person
what a loser
and then the cops you up and say don't
do it again and you're like yeah yeah
yeah so so when when people feel like
they've got a community that will
support them and they can rise up they
will you know what happens when everyone
feels like everyone hates them for what
they did that no back down in two
seconds because they don't want to be
ostracized you know yeah that's scary
man
I think well I think the funny thing
about it is we are so ridiculously far
away from that yeah we are but you have
people screeching that like Donald Trump
is they come they come a Cheeto Hitler
it's like dude are you kidding me
like the Democrats just like throw a
temper tantrum for 10 minutes and all of
a sudden his entire plan is derailed
like it's actually working like the the
checks and balances are working overtime
so it works
yeah like when they were when the
impeachment stuff happened they were
supposed to go to the Supreme Court it
was a file a suit with the courts
demanding that Trump send his people to
testify instead they just impeached him
for it it's like okay you can't do that
and then a court ruled against them
saying like one of the guys they were
trying to get to testify the court said
you can't do that so it basically shot
them down but as far as I'm concerned if
we have a system in the Constitution
that says the kind of legislative branch
will go to the judicial to sort out you
know beef with the executive etc and
they bypass that I'm pretty sure we
don't have that much executive power for
me to actually be worried all that much
yeah you know it's like what has really
happened
he's a border policy trade policy the
economy was doing really great up until
this so nah man I don't like a lot of
his environmental stuff this
environmental stuff is really really bad
but that's why it's not but that's one
of the reasons the economy is doing
really well true because he says jobs
are created
no deregulating yeah exactly massive
massive exporter of fossil fuels yeah
that's true there's the big challenge
man so so I'll tell you what the real
challenge is you got beef with China you
think China bed yeah are you asking me
yeah I'm asking you think China's bed I
think I think China is a product that of
what we of ourselves also you know where
it happened are they know I mean it's
you don't think what they're doing is
bad yeah it's like okay yeah absolutely
locking people in camps harvesting
organs yeah yeah that is terrible
welding the doors shut yeah of course
but so here's our product of what we've
allowed them yeah exactly thank you what
do you Nabal that what what do you mean
we know we gave them all of our you know
job isn't it
actually yeah you know so we enabled
that and now they sell everything to the
world and they've yeah our manufacturing
you know so so here's what ends up
happening because I've been talking
about this for a long time I was talking
about this before
trunk not even got elected if I would
always say this to people if you want to
live in wealth and prosperity then or
actually I'll put a different way we are
competing with China they are rapidly
growing they are displacing America as
the global superpower yeah they are
dominating manufacturing they're taking
our manufacturing they're taking jobs
from everybody they're colonizing other
places through not it's not true it's
not colonization the way they tell you
the history books are they getting a
button and go land somewhere and put a
flag in the ground yeah they're just
moving places because their population
is so massive they need to move out and
it's it's literally of you know it's its
extender call almost to European
colonization where the population was
booming
yeah people wanted their own land if you
want to live in a global society because
that's where we're headed dominated by
China's version of government by all
means sit around and do nothing if you
want to make sure that Western democracy
and the ideals we hold dominate the
planet and we spread the ideas of free
speech and free expression the United
States absolutely has to to expand
culturally and economically faster than
China does as long as we are giving away
everything to China not only were they
growing we were diminishing yeah exactly
Trump comes in and says turn it around
mm-hmm flip it he says we're gonna bring
the jobs back we're gonna secure our
borders and we're gonna grow again and
so there's the big challenge do you do
you like the environment you wanna
protect the trees I certainly do but
then there's the challenge of how do we
compete with China who is burning their
own their own cities to the ground and I
mean that figuratively with trash
pollution and everyone's gagging and
eating gutter oil they are sacrificing
everything pure reckless abandon to
rapidly expand faster than we are now
they have more millionaires than we do
and that means if we're on this
trajectory for the next 50 to 100 years
boom all of a sudden we hear in the
night states will be learning you know
we're gonna have Mandarin classes you're
gonna be praising you know
xi jinping's grandson or whoever the
Communist Party leader is I mean there's
a Chinatown in every city I mean but
that's fine like they have a mirror I
know if America town and stuff
the problem is when was that NBA guy who
was like not on Trigon China man was it
wasn't it Kobe no no it was not Kobe no
no LeBron right so when this this dude
in the NBA criticized China's
heavy-handedness over Hong Kong mm-hmm
Hong Kong threatened the NBA we're gonna
cut you off you're gonna know money from
us unless you apologize and all of a
sudden all these NBA people started
coming out bending their pathetic
wobbling little knees to the Chinese
government saying you know we don't
really know much about their culture and
that's wrong we shouldn't say that and
then I think it was Steve Kerr who was
like someone asked him about what was
going on at Hong Kong and he goes they
don't ask me about guns in America we
got our problems and people were like
dude we're talking about them locking up
a million Muslims and harvesting their
organs for sale yeah you want to
complain about some crazy people with
guns so that's what's scary yeah this is
this this is my scary china rant yeah I
was waiting yeah dude
so when people's are complaining that
Trump is deregulating and taking up this
land you know this is basically why he's
doing it yeah and I think it's I think
it's terrible but I don't know the
alternative is let China expand
uncontrolled unchecked one of the
reasons for the European Union was
because the massive expansion of China
and that and that the idea was that
these countries had to come together and
have a unifying body to compete with how
massive China is becoming otherwise in a
hundred years yeah there's gonna be
camps here and and they will be the
dominant superpower
they'll be exporting their culture to us
and then all of these authoritarian
norms that they're enacting which our
celebrities are already bending the knee
to there we go
not all celebrities not all of them but
but in a hundred years yeah so what do
we do what do we do about I don't know
man I honestly don't know well we should
start by making our own medicine
seriously I start yep didn't they say
like AHA well we can just hold it hold
the medicine and you guys will be
screwed yeah they're like a week ago is
that we'll drown you in a sea of
coronavirus yeah you know what you don't
really messed up but you don't really
pissed me off
in September Trump ordered US firms to
come back to the US right many said yes
and then a week later US officials said
our dependence on Chinese medicine is
åsa and medical supplies is a serious
national security threat in September so
what would have happened if back then
Trump issued you know he ordered for him
to come back but what if there was a
really heavy executive policy saying you
must build these things in this country
they would have called him a tyrant yeah
they would have said you know
Chito Hitler all that stuff now we're at
a point where it's too late yeah we
don't have the medicine and we're honor
what you know we're begging yeah what do
we do open it together trying to make a
vaccine it's like when hope it works
when these advisors came out and said
these officials that it's a serious
threat someone from China said if the
that the the in any of there would be no
circumstance where China would withhold
medicine or anything for the United
States and it's absurd to think so now
they're laughing about it yeah they're
gloating they could take it all the way
from us so I you know to what end
well what is there what is their goal
there were they just simply suing that
it was there some context do you know I
don't know you know but it's like what
would it's so devilish to hear someone
say that and think that like why would
we like brush it off and not still be
talking about it yeah seriously I don't
understand why why isn't the news like
can you believe they said that like like
because basically because the the
economic ties just like the NBA people
being like no no no don't rag on China
no no no don't do that how crazy is it
that these same people will go on
Twitter and screech to to to hell you
know about how awful Trump is just like
re like the whole time yeah and then
when it comes to China like whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa wait a minute
wait a minute you don't know the whole
truth don't wreck on China you don't you
don't Orange everything about them or
demand bet not what your Chinese people
are the same it's it's inverted it
should be like China is a nightmarish
hellhole and Trump you know and he's got
problems yeah you know I mean thanks for
checking out this segment from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show every
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
sometimes an hour or two and we do
have a full live recorded version of the
show that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you